suite à ça il ya un blogueur qui
s'appelle aquabike s'est emparé de la
sphère qui enquête depuis longtemps sur
les rumeurs de prostitution dans la télé
réalité entre temps sur youtube et
anglais a mis une autre vidéo un
commentaire pour dire que ces photos en
fait il les avait juste mise pour
illustrer le sujet et qui ne les
connaissais pas personnellement d'accord
là aujourd'hui c'est parole contre
parole les influences dans question
disent qu'elles vont attaquer toutes les
personnes bien sûr les dénigrent
lorsqu'elles sont victimes de
harcèlement et le blogueur à coyecques
dit lui qu'il a des preuves concrètes et
c'est ça qu'on attend des preuves
concrètes d'accord parce que là la
vallasse de celle combat maeva elle fait
pas ça du tout voilà s'il n'y a aucune
preuve concrète aujourd'hui ce sont que
des rumeurs il ya des gens qui affirme
détenir des preuves et c'est ça qu'il
faut sortir si c'est le cas si tu nous
regardes et alors il ya deux choses il
ya d'abord comment ça se passait donc là
bas elle été recrutés pour des soirées
elles ne savaient pas forcément que des
pratiques scabreuses ou délirantes
allait se produire elle arrivait dans
une chambre après avoir rendez vous avec
un milliardaire et elle se trouvait
souvent face à quatre hommes des gardes
du corps aient été forcés à des choses
et pour les forcer parfois elle était
droguée donc après il y avait
effectivement
défécation sur elle
forcer à manger leur vomi des rapports
sexuels avec des animaux non et le chant
et le chantage c'est le chantage c'était
drogue et ont confisqué les papiers ont
leur confisquer leurs papiers comme il y
avait plusieurs hommes parfois il y
avait même des pratiques avec plusieurs
hommes alors je vais vous donner je vais
vous ce qui est sorti on a travaillé
avec guillaume il ya une liste notamment
aquabaie va donner je précise que cette
liste que je vais vous donner de noms
tout le monde dément et que c'est une
liste de personnes qui auraient été
jean-paul conditionnelle à qui aurait
été escorte d'accord c'est pas forcément
des gens qui se serait livré à ces
pratiques scabreuses mais néanmoins
c'est une liste de gens qui auraient pu
baisser nist
véridique ou pas ces gens démentent mais
c'est sa liste circule c'est comme vous
voulez je peux vous donner les noms des
gens qui sont cités entre paris et dubaï
pour cet otan cerner
ghazi un peu violemment à comment cela
ces merdes
[Rires]
les agressions c'est pas du tout alors
il y a il y a il est haï lire pour
beaucoup dans ces pratiques scabreuses y
lire pour beaucoup des agressions à et
je vais même vous dire
quelque chose ou pas porté plainte je
vois daniel moreau là
j'apprécie que c'est comme vous voulez
connaît pas titre ne percera mais c'est
comme rouler non mais non balaban on me
donne pas de noms mais c'est une
régression elles ont porté plainte et ce
concessionnaire n'a rien pas de plainte
c'est comme vous voulez bon alors il ya
il ya des escortes d'avant et il ya des
et score d'aujourd'hui et je vais aussi
vous révéler quelque chose c'est que
j'ai parlé aujourd'hui avec un
influenceur il est révérend protestants
et et influenceurs africain il est à en
côte d'ivoire
camille makosso il m'a révélé qu'il y
avait 1000 femmes africaines 1000 femmes
africaines qui étaient recrutés
notamment par un réseau tik tok pour
être esclaves sexuelles à dubaï il ya
trois hommes femmes camerounaises qui
ont disparu il ya eu un suicide ces
demis des mannequins des actrices
cameroun côte d'ivoire sénégal plein de
pays il est effrayé il ya un réseau il
ya des humiliations raciste et lui se
mobilisent pour que ça cesse c'est une
pratique alors on donne pas de noms mais
honnêtement série c'est une pratique qui
est en train de prendre une expansion
incroyable délirante folle et
scandaleuse à dubaï